okay so
uh the drill we started with is you can
move out of the way
uh
the drill you started with
is just this
okay
let's see kitty guys just change the
stances
but to go into more detail
is
just generally for slow training you
want to
not
push into them
instead the
way you can imagine it is that there's a
hook
on the top crown of your head so not the
top of your head because that would
violate the chin position
you get the
chin positioning the crown positioning
and then
everything hangs from that and you start
to sink into the mat okay
so this ability to relax and not press
into the
a precursor to not bracing
what you tend to do brace under the mat
as opposed to
letting their energy through you to the
mat letting it back through you out to
them if you were doing culture or
letting it in through you
coming back out and matching their level
of energy for the ik adhesion but in
either case
i'm very relaxed and
kind of hanging
and sinking into the mat from that as
opposed to push pushing on the mat which
will only happen
or has to happen with lower leg tension
now even if you
tense your shoulders you might feel like
oh i'm really tense there but you're
tense in your lower legs too
okay
and you're pushing into the mat so you
can't do the internal aspects of the arm
so slow training or static training
should have this hanging relaxing
feeling okay
so that you can get it
you still have the kitty to do
all right so some things to pay
attention to
[Music]
as i move into this
stance
if my
foot goes wide into this kind of kama
head
the only way you did that is you pushed
with the left foot
so
if i had the hanging principle
that's about how deep i can be
and let that foot hang
in order to go past
further out from my hips
you had to push with that foot to do
that you see
and so now you're going to push again
turn push again
to get that distance
instead let it be a hanging drill
hanging drill
drop
we already told you where to focus lower
legs pay attention to your lower legs
release the lower legs we gave you an
attention tool hanging
next thing
there is a rotation
this this rotation that you're doing
this imaginary point you
yes there's a line of attack but there's
a point of attack too so yes you could
extend the line of attack from 12
o'clock to 6 o'clock
but
i am actually the target so there's a
point
it's always going to be on 12 to 6
but
it's not back there
it's in it's around here okay
and that's what i go around so
around that point
drop
there it is again around that point
thirdly
watch
the
as with everything you have to do this
but you can go too far
you see
now i'm in some goofy ass
totally not martial stance
you see that
i mean this crazy ass type rope thing
when you bring back the sword and you do
that stuff
come around
you get this weird angle you see that is
what the heck is that okay
where does this sword want to cut this
sword wants to cut over here but that's
where the target was you got it
so
when you're talking about hanging
that means tension free
tension free
so when you come all the way around
again
there's tension in you how do you know
just just relax you you can't stay still
you see that
you could
feel oh yeah across my inner knee
across my inner knee i will way over oh
god today across my inner knee usually
you get so used to that that you think
that's good form
but you were told
drop and relax
okay
so you're trying to do it but yay
holy cow you're on the tight rope and
you have tension all in your ankles and
your knees which is not correct and you
have the incorrect angle for the attack
of your own okay
so let's get those three things going go
okay so this is a a pair drill in and
relaxing okay
what we're ultimately trying to do
is uh
get the hanging sets so that i can bring
that into my cocky
and uh the hanging stance of the sword
a lot of people think this is cookie
it's not cookie okay here
that
the way it bounced back up that's hokey
you understand that that energy went
down came back out and the sword bounced
up so this is not cookie
that's just tension okay so relax
that part comes up
so you have to learn how to hang
okay
so i'm going to be doing that
in the pear drill
okay
so first you're going to watch me and
then i'll i'll show the rule okay
but he's gonna do his best so i come up
and i'm just doing that girl
i'm just doing my room
okay now i have to show his rule his
draw okay now remember uke is always
working on the same thing that nag is
working on so your kid's always hanging
too okay
so i'm gonna recommend that you get let
go of your your uh
samurai fight
take your hand off of it because it'll
make you make
okay so we're gonna take our hand off of
it and this i'm hanging the same way
with my body and so is the sword the
sword is hanging i'm not
putting tension into it okay
so as he goes up i'm just resting on him
do you see
i'm not fencing him
i
move so that he picks my sword up and
lets my sword fall
okay
we'll put it on his let my sword fall
it's on him
let it fall
on him
let it fall and you could see it like
may
you're
too square
you see that so you need more
obliqueness to this dance so
a lot of you are changing you're
clearing the line
but you're clearing the lines square
square
you see so your hips are square
that means you didn't do the rotation we
talked about you just
turn like this
you didn't rotate here
rotate here do you see that so you see
how much more oblique i am
this is where a lot of you are
and don't change it for now all right as
a result
as he goes up you hit the elbow you see
boom
up hit the elbow you see that because
that elbow did not get pulled back with
the hip because we did not
rotate on a single pivot point we just
changed our angle
like this
okay your pivot point is somewhere back
here if you pay attention it's around
here whereas the other one is over here
boom
over here
back here
do you see okay
try the drill again
um
the drill is very difficult
we we can't get to the drill because the
uke cannot do the settling and just like
in kihon was that uk's
understanding of the internal aspects is
a subtle understanding which means it
requires more skill okay
i have a feeling that the reason
modern nagi
went with choreographed uke
is
they didn't need the
the skills they didn't have the skills
to throw someone so they made someone
throw themselves
but
uk also did not have the skills to
actually be thrown
and so
they kind of behind closed doors made a
secret handshake i don't throw you
cool i'll throw myself all right let's
do it okay and that's kind of what's
happening in this drill too
uh he is trying to hang and relax
well i'm trying to hang and relax okay
and uh
what you're
what you're seeing is as you go in and
you have an attention here you
are now lifting pushing up off the
ground you see that
as opposed to there's no there's no
intention
so my hand isn't doing anything weird
staying up
having a hang time
accelerating down
it's just relax
relax
relax i have to release the same way
that he has to release okay you got that
all right so we're gonna try it
okay i'm gonna go up and now he's
resting on me just relax and
rest okay and you're gonna see where i
i'm not gonna turn like this
going to turn here boom his weapon is
going to miss me then he's going to
relax
up
rest
rest on my sword okay
and again i'm going to turn over here
oh he'll miss that elbow again
relax
okay again
again let it drop
come on or ass
let it drop boom
again
let it rest rest everything resting
drop boom again
rest
okay put your arm back out where it was
and you can see my angle okay
some of you
go back and continue
and here let it rest and you're over
here
you see that here you went too far
and now you've got that torque across
your front inner knee
and you're in that goofy tightrope
stance got it
and your point of rotation
was bach which means you did not clear
the line you're on the line you're on
the line you're on the line on the line
on the line on the line on the line
finally off the line as opposed to
off the line you got it okay
so watch that crazy angle you should be
able to touch his arm i touched his arm
and didn't kill you did it okay so let's
go
okay
okay so we're gonna take that drill uh
and look at it uh internally okay so uh
he's
i if i brace on this mat in this shallow
stance then he's gonna push me over okay
but he's trying to push me over so
instead i'm just i'm just hanging i'm
just hanging okay uh and all his energy
all his energy has gone through me okay
and now i have to do the technique so
i don't want to push on the mat and try
to push him back right because what
let's say you got there
you're not going to be putting this foot
there it's going to push you off okay
so uh what i'm trying to do is we're
here and i'm going to try to rotate
around this thing
remember i'm not gonna try to
rotate somewhere back here
okay
i want i want to immediately
rotate off of that thing okay
so you could be straight to the front
he's pushing on me and i'm going to
rotate
here
okay that's my that's my
job
so watch it here
whoa
whoa that's not it
okay you're here
okay try it again
so it's it's it's deceptive just like
when you're trying to do the the kitty
it's deceptive it's deceptive on what
you're doing okay and this looks like
you're like
trying to do something like that so um
the
the problem of the of the pressure you
can see okay now he braced on the floor
you see and now once he the energy did
not go through him and now
he is uh
you're going to have the problem of the
of the bracing so i'm just holding this
this penetration point
and then he's going you can go kind of
slow and you see that it's as he starts
to move out of the brace it compromises
balance do you see that
so that was him trying to
push in
maintain the brace but move and you
can't you cannot do that which is why
you often see
navis
takes pauses in there in the sequence of
their nage mazda because they were
bracing
and uh
now stops right and the only time they
don't stop is when the choreographed uk
was never
providing any kind of actual
problem for them you see so this is like
a problem okay
so
i just want you to feel
it and so he he did it again
um i don't can you see it or no you
can't see it okay so uh
you see though so already it's it
because the initial energy can't go
through you
um i'll demonstrate it okay so when
taylor is trying to push me and i can go
on one foot it doesn't doesn't matter
okay uh because the energy is going
through me down on the ground so uh
there's a very finite limit and it's
quite low marginally speaking on how
much energy you could take so as i just
pushed a little you see
he would lose that bracing angle war
okay
so
that's the first thing and that is why
all true non-contestation is only
possible internally if you cannot
non-contest
by moving around externally it's not
possible you you are doing these little
micro bracing you're just not aware of
it okay
so uh we'll i'm gonna ease up the
tension did you feel me ease up the
tension so we don't get that i'm gonna
operate at outside where he wants to
brace okay so i'm not triggering his
bracing but as he goes to move now there
it is again did you see that you did it
now he pushed into me okay so i'll let
you keep going so they can see that
there it is right there you see
can't put the foot there do you guys see
that
so he goes
well okay so i'm gonna again i'm gonna
ease off again to not trigger his his
brace so i'm just here at his surface
i'm not doing spinal displacement so
that he has to ground that energy so i'm
just here i'm going to ease up there
and then i come over here
look at the last one okay
so
he's going i'm going to ease up sorry
i'm gonna ease up and then
i'm gonna come in you see and this is
what we all think is
is what you saw but it's not what you
saw okay it's not what you saw he's a
big strong guy and he's pushing there's
a lot of energy there okay
um so this again goes back to the
choreographed ukia so the coriander
affluent who never presents the problem
and then lets themselves go in you see
uh if i didn't have any energy into his
spinal displacement
and he goes
why should i have stepped in
do you see that
on the other one i'm pushing it so when
he takes away
the point of contention by first
internalizing it well i would keep going
forward okay so as a result
um because i don't do this one i
probably will not be able to overpower
people like we think we will uh it'll
probably compromise my mobility
but
i won't have them fall into that
magic one inch two inch past their
intention which is the precursor for the
kazushi angles that we're going to take
you see what we what we tend to do
instead with the choreographed uk is he
goes and the choreography
gets themselves past that
into that one two inches of over
extension you see and now aikidoka think
uh
especially non aikidoka i think it only
works on the dude who overextends
themselves
everyone will overextend themselves when
the target
is not where it's supposed to be
do you get it and i don't need them to
four feet over extend themselves boom
that was enough okay which we'll show
you next okay all right try the drill
again okay so he's going
into the ground around
[Music]
into the ground
it's tighter and shorter
it's also not
and this drill is
so you get out of this
this space
as as intensity increases your mind is
actually tighter but it doesn't mean
you're contesting
do you understand does it mean you're
like
[Music]
but you're not out here
things are tighter
okay
try it again
okay so we're here and he it goes into
the ground i do the same disappearance
whoa
again you'll see the tightness
as soon as as soon as you touch him that
as soon as he touches you then you can
do it i'm not going like this
as soon as as soon as i feel him that's
what i'm trying to let go
okay
i'll kind of go static
down you're gonna do it static boom
you're gonna do it stack it quietly so
right here you charge our
charger
or you're gonna have over he just
touches
but i'm going in
not around
it's shield
[Music]
and you get the two inches you get
it's an inch all i need is an inch half
inch even does it okay
and you get the
what technically is over penetration but
not choreographed over penetration okay